i have this disorder i have my
dissociative identity oh my god that's
horrible dude are you i do that's crazy
oh hold on i'm disassociated right now
[Music]
what up dog [ __ ] dog what's going on
man what's up dude what's your name dawg
uh my my my name's tyrone dawg like i'm
from i'm from cincinnati
that's what's up you got some weed on
you tyrone [ __ ] you know i do what you
need dog
i'm not gonna lie i already like tyrone
between you and me you're way cooler
than royce yeah i
mean i don't even want that royce guy to
come back all right um
it's kind of mean wait i thought you
[Laughter]
uh can you get tyrone back because that
guy was really cool
no i can't hold on tyrone's telling me
something he said he went to go
get cigarettes he'll be right back so
we'll see if tyrone shows up
[Music]
by the way royce has several
personalities too he also has a
personality his name is royce hey stop
just don't tell people what's your
what's the name what's the name of your
personality royce i guess the same guy
[ __ ] same dude oh [ __ ]
it's just you just zone out like she
does for like two minutes
and then start blinking and then you
come back and you're like same voice
go suck your dick and you're like wait a
minute is that even a new personality
no i just knot it off for a second i was
tired when it comes to your dick
tyrone's telling me something right now
he wants to know if he can hold your
phone for me yeah
yo can i yo can i hold your phone for a
second just for a minute yo
or do you got a charger so i could
charge mine
i could charge mines on your on your
charger okay
i'll tell you what could i i don't even
need your phone but can you give me a
wi-fi password
so i can check my facebook or my phone
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's like yeah man like i ain't paying
my phone bill or whatever but if you let
me use your wi-fi
i could let my wee guy know through
facebook messenger
that i need to meet up with him wait
he's saying something
he said if you're going to the store can
you get some backwoods
he says you'll know what that means can
you get me some backwoods
and some [ __ ] crab chips please thank
you
he wants to store brand spicy cheetos
hey man yeah can you give me some hot
cheetos
and uh one of them [ __ ] uh
what they got there one of them purple
bug juices doing for a quarter
so that's all we got it all right look
so i'm i i want to say that i also have
this disorder so i've ever seen anything
uncool for anything that's that you
would find to be breaking terms of
service it's one of my halts yo while
you're there can you do me a favor you
buy me two new ports
you're like two packs of newport just
like nine two six no you gotta go to the
other store on hillsboro
they got lucy's okay perfect
that's when you know you're in a good
neighborhood when they sell lucy's which
by the way is so highly illegal
you're not allowed to do that but did
that dude get killed in new york for it
no not on the streets i mean in stores
oh yeah of course these guys
you just go and like i've been in so
many ghetto
like when i was trying to quit smoking
and it's really hard to quit smoking
when you live at a place that has lucy's
because then it's like all right
you could just go in there and be like
let me get one cigarette
and guess what there's only one kind of
cigarette
i swear to god you can't find regular
cigarettes that are lucy's you can't
like if you go in and go
you got a non-menthol lucy they'll be
like no only newport
um i'm sorry micah i'm disassociating
again really quick
oh god
what are you i'm a cruise ship director
oh
what are you rich foss yeah i just
disassociated
it's great any [ __ ] up in here this
is actually the straightest version of
royce
this is the straightest version of roy
straight as he gets guys
toot all right i think we're done with
this video i didn't know i didn't know
one of royce's personalities was
one of the stars of fat love boat
or just love but it was filmed today
it's true um
american love boat yeah american love
though this is
the boat but it takes place on a
carnival cruise it's like love boat
except we can only let half the amount
of passengers on legally now
all right we're done uh but so whatever
she has a fake disease i guess the whole
point of all this